and i remember practicing
to sit like him
because this is not my natural way right
like forcing my little legs to like do
this you know what i mean
and then like just act act kind of like
an artist almost this is so gross what
i'm saying right and so it's like
from then on like i just pretend to be
this thing like this artist guy this is
so annoying that i'm what i i because
i'm i'm i want to change right so i
think it all stems from rick farr
this guy this guy you know what i mean
man i'm still thrown off by that crazy
slur you just used
which one
the g word on yourself yeah my little g
legs
g money likes what i say
we can't say it i can't i wouldn't care
we can't we can't say it
what did i say paul what did he say
that's probably going to demonetize this
whole podcast right that one word do you
think so heavyweight can you beep it
yeah yeah
all the time do you ever get in trouble
for that on youtube
well i think that if a black guy says
the n-word it's okay right
and uh that was a problem yeah it's a
problem yeah yeah but i think that as an
asian person i can say
the g word yeah no no no we meant
[Music]
yeah yeah okay
with the m yeah you said it with the m
right i think can you say that like can
you say ook with a g
like spelling
that's probably fine it's fine
right but i'm just saying that um
so he said egypt right but he is an
idiot so why can't he say that
right that was and that was actually the
point he was making while he said it he
was telling a story right about it
getting cut out of jackass too when he
was the one who said it and he was like
i'm the one who said it oh god it got
cut out and it got our i remember it
maybe who cares but but yeah it was yeah
it you know it's um
i'm gonna say something and i i want to
be it's a sensitive time yeah it's not
only a sensitive time but um
i have to
i think when it comes to comedy
right
this is
i think we're going to be in a very
scary territory
if we start completely editing
everything that we're saying
i mean especially in comedy in comedy
and i and i um
i struggle with it because it's like you
know
everything that i say on podcasts and
radio shows and stuff
are number one pretty much lies
number two they are pretty much live
exaggerated stories
i'm wild i say wild things you know and
um
you know that's always been since
after mad tv i was always kind of like
of a shock
kind of a shock comic you know i mean
saying crazy things and stuff like that
and showing your wiener yeah yeah i used
to i may not show the actual wiener but
i would go dance in my underwear or
whatever right and be provocative in
that way and i just you know it's
there's a freedom to that i live in
america you know i mean i handled this
little asian guy you know i mean i wanna
you know i mean i wanna express myself
you know
and um
we're just in a really scary time man
because it's like
you know we have to watch everything we
say stuff that i've said before like 20
years ago or coming back around and
people are going well you said have you
gotten in trouble for a drink
i don't want to talk about it but i have
you know i mean and it's like those
things that i'm in trouble for
are complete and utter
lies and exaggerations they're jokes and
you know they
and i feel bad i guess i you know i mean
there's a part of me that feels bad but
it's like
you know at the end of the day it's like
my core being is i've never really done
anything to harm anybody or
you know i've done anything i've always
been sober a guy i've always been you
know my little brief moments of relapse
but it's like i um
i know that it sounds like your relapse
looks more like you in fetal position
than out there being hateful
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude